[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue d'emprunt de
vue ravis d'accueillir nos deux
débatteurs habitués du vendredi bonsoir
ferghana ziari vous êtes chargé d'études
au think tank iref vous êtes aussi
délégué général de l'académie libre des
sciences humaines et puis bon soir
guillaume bernard comme d'une ligne
offrent désormais vous êtes maître de
conférences à l'institut catholique
d'études supérieures et auteur de la
guerre à droite aura bien lieu
le mouvement dextrogyre c'était chez des
clubs où air jeudi c'était parce qu'un
livre a été publié en 2016 oui il est
toujours d'actualité toujours
d'actualité il y aura des nouveautés
cette année très bien et n'ont qu'une
réédition à venir sans doute et puis
d'autres ouvrages à d'autres ouvrages
briquet vous nous raconterez ça ce soir
je vous propose de commencer par parler
des frontières
est ce que vous vous souvenez de cette
déclaration qui avait été faite par
olivier ferrand c'était il ya très
longtemps juste avant le premier
confinement fermer les frontières ça ne
sert à rien nous avait-il d un virus ça
ne s'arrête pas aux frontières
sauf qu'apparemment le gouvernement
français a fini par changer d'avis les
frontières ne sont pas encore fermés
mais les contrôles se multiplient on a
apprit ainsi que un test pcr de moins de
72 heures serait demandée à l'entrée en
france en tout cas l'entrée dans les
aéroports et dans les ports y compris
pour les citoyens de l'union européenne
de son côté angela merkel explique
qu'elle n'exclut pas de fermer les
frontières y compris les frontières avec
les les ressortissants du reste de
l'union écouter ce qu'on pense clément
bonus et le secrétaire d'état chargé des
affaires européennes
un europhile convaincu mais quand même
il est bien obligé de reconnaître que
peut-être il va falloir revoir ce qu'ils
considéraient comme acquis c'est à dire
les frontières ouvertes comprend des
mesures proportionnées
franchement il n'y a aucun tabou
là-dessus mais je ne veux pas pour ça
que je le disais tout à l'heure qu'on
fasse croire aux gens que la frontière
fermée ou même la frontière contrôlé
c'est le remède miracle
c'est un outil on l'utilisent vous le
voyez de manière concrète pragmatique
mais ça ne sera pas la seule manière oui
d'éviter que le virus soit sur les bancs
de bois
c'est un virus contre la libre
circulation des personnes sur un quasi
arrêt ou c'est juste un retour au bon
sens t je pense que le fait que le virus
est entamée à la liberté de circulation
maintenant on l'a constaté depuis un an
puisque on a restauré des frontières
dans tous les aspects de notre vie on
nous intime de pratiquer une
distanciation social à l'échelle de la
vie quotidienne on limite les
déplacements à l'intérieur même de la
nation du territoire national donc la
question l'achat nation qui consiste à
dire que les frontières seraient
complètement inefficace et stupide
puisque la doctrine même de la
distanciation sociale qui consiste à
aplatir la fameuse courbe des
contaminations est fondé sur le constat
que en limitant les interactions
humaines ont limité non violence est ce
que on avait enfermé 60 millions de
français chez eux pour leur bien je ne
souhaitais pas mais les frontières et
les ouverte vous pouviez continuer à
quitter le pays et y entrer librement
j'espère que je critique c'est le fait
qu'on ait enfermer les gens dans les
yeux c'est à dire vous auriez tous
laissés ouverts au delà de c'est à dire
que la caisse je ne crois pas qu'il
faille réduire la question la question
des frontières à une simple question
virologiques
est ce qu'on doit réduire la société un
simple virus est ce qu'on considère est
ce qu'on n'est pas en droit de
considérer en tant que membre une
société que une société ne se réduit pas
à un virus qu'il existe de plus haute
considération qui nous conduit à
considérer que certains principes y
compris la liberté individuelle sont non
négociables pas parce qu'on aime les
virus et parce qu'on considère que levet
suspendre ses principes
ça nous exposerait à des mots peut-être
plus insupportable encore que la
pandémie
donc c'est la question du rapport coût
bénéfice des mesures que l'on prend je
crois que clément boon a raison quand il
dit que la frontière ne n'est pas un
remède miracle
aujourd'hui on soupçonne la corée du
nord d'être elle aussi atteinte par le
coronavirus vous voyez que même le pays
le plus fermé de la planète n'est pas
et contre contrôler ce risque là
maintenant en admettant même que réduire
les que fermer les frontières que
réduire les déplacements individuels est
une efficacité en matière épidémique est
ce que la fin justifie les moyens est ce
qu'il n'ya pas aussi des des principes
et des objectifs plus élevés qu on est
en droit de mettre au dessus tout
simplement de la nécessité de lutter
contre cette pandémie
guillaume bernard vous êtes convaincu
ses nouveaux jouets c'est de voir les
frontières revenir sur le principe oui
sur le principe je suis assez je trouve
la situation juste assez jubilatoire
parce que le gouvernement est obligé de
reconnaître qu'effectivement une
frontière ça peut être utile qu'une
frontière ou réclamer l'existence d'une
frontière ça n'est pas et bien une paroi
étanche ça peut s'ouvrir ça peut se
faire mais ça peut laisser passer
certaines choses dans un sens ou dans un
autre
et pas de manière systématique donc déjà
le retour des frontières sur le principe
je crois que c'est une une victoire
symbolique sur il vient une idéologie du
libre échangisme que je ne que je ne
partage pas bien cela dit il ya
effectivement la question de savoir
pourquoi ils rétablissent savane
frontières je ne suis pas tout à fait
certain que sur la question du virus ou
que les mesures qui sont prises seront
suffisantes ou même qu'elle soit
légitimé ces deux aspects différents
j'en conviens et mon propos pourraient
être précisées mais en tout cas voilà
c'est contraint et forcé qu'il prenne
ces mesures donc de ce point de vue là
ça ne me paraît pas satisfaisant ça ne
remettra sans doute pas en cause dans la
pensée de nos gouvernants je dirais leur
adhésion aux principes du libre
échangisme alors que pour ma part je
suis plutôt favorable au principe de la
possibilité d'avoir recours au
protectionnisme mais enfin tout de même
symboliquement c'est assez c'est assez
satisfaisant
je constate simplement et là je dois
dire que je suis extrêmement choquée que
en gala merkel a trouvé parfaitement
intelligent d'accueillir un million de à
migron 1,1 million de d'immigrés
clandestins mais qu'en revanche elle est
prête à fermer les frontières
il avait prévu un voile pour le virus
bon voilà il n'y avait pas le cosy de
bon voilà je la situation est quand même
compliquée et symboliquement parlant le
retour des frontières c'est quand même
extrêmement savoureux
je trouve les propos de guillaume assez
contradictoire puisque depuis quelques
mois avec moi vous vous justement
effrayés de des atteintes aux libertés
individuelles que légitime ces virus
alors pourquoi la libre circulation
serais tu
un principe on pourrait écorner alors
alors même que c'est une atteinte à la
liberté qui est tout aussi grave que
toutes celles que l'on subit depuis
bientôt un an
pourquoi se réjouir de la fermeture des
frontières non mais je veux dire que en
l'occurrence son pari le complice
téléphone puisse fermer les frontières
c'est un fait maintenant c'est à quel
prix et à quel coût
on s'est dit que l'effondrement du
commerce national produit une isère
sociale effroyable et ceci partout à la
fois dans les pays développés dans les
pays émergents et dans les pays en voie
de développement
je ne suis pas sûr qu'il faut qu'il
faille se réjouir de cette fermeture
parce que c'est une véritable défaite
pour l'humanité et qui sera extrêmement
coûteux sur le plan humanitaire et l
intérêt de la région de ferghana
je rappelle que vous vous êtes souvent
élevés sur ce plateau chaque bernard
contre les mesures privatives de liberté
pour les gars sur absolument non alors
merci de me permettre de préciser ma
pensée
les raisons pour lesquelles les
frontières sont fermées aujourd'hui ne
me paraissent pas être les bonnes
en revanche qu'il puisse y avoir des
frontières pour réguler l'immigration le
commerce ça ça me paraît parfaitement
légitime parce que il n'ya pas dans la
vie sociale que les individus il ya
aussi les corps sociaux et je pense que
une nation par exemple a parfaitement le
droit à a persisté dans son identité a
le droit à défendre ses particularismes
a le droit de protéger son industrie
athènes son industrie où son agriculture
face à une concurrence qui pourrait être
déloyale donc sur le principe qu'il
puisse y avoir des frontières
je me réjouis qu'elle revienne mais je
m'interroge effectivement en revanche là
je serais plutôt d'accord avec vous sur
les raisons qui ont poussé à fermer les
frontières aujourd'hui ce sujet vous
intéresse de toute évidence et vous
réagissez sur lefigaro.fr sur youtube ou
sur notre fil twitter écoutez ces
quelques réactions celle de gamme état
qui considère comme et d'or que et
beaucoup d'autres que le gouvernement
aurait dû prendre cette décision
bien plutôt fleur de provence sur
lefigaro.fr si le test est négatif mais
que la personne et contaminantes ce qui
arrive
le système est défaillant est donc cet
internaute serait favorable à
l'instauration d'une quarantaine
obligatoires nicole 06 le gouvernement
n'avait-il pas dit au printemps dernier
que ça ne servait à rien de fermer les
frontières et bien si chez nicole
d'ailleurs on a rappelé tout à l'heure
avec la déclaration d'olivier véran une
question de chypre hunter sur
lefigaro.fr
est ce que les travailleurs frontaliers
bénéficieront d'une exemption
alors oui et d'ailleurs c'est l'une des
raisons pour lesquelles le gouvernement
français
et si réticents à mettre des mesures
trop radical c'est pour ne pas gêner les
travailleurs frontaliers lyon sur
youtube je ne pense pas que ce soit très
grave de fermer les frontières
l'époque est difficile et puis c'est de
la com c'est un joli pseudo sur
lefigaro.fr à nouveau qui vérifiera si
le test a été fait les compagnies
aériennes où la police les compagnies
elles ont intérêt à remplir leurs avions
c'est vrai mais en même temps si elles
ont des amendes pour avoir fait monter
un passager sans test ça va peut-être
les rendre raisonnable alors il ya
l'aveuglent sur lefigaro.fr qui nous
propose cette jolie métaphore fermer la
porte du poulailler
lorsque le renard est déjà dedans c'est
grotesque effectivement c'est peut-être
c'est peut-être trop tard et puis cette
question de louis oms qui décide de la
fermeture des frontières est l'union
européenne ou bien les états et bien sûr
le principe c'est l'union européenne à
travers les accords de schengen mais
chaque état est autorisé à prendre des
mesures dérogatoires en k2 en cas de
besoin je voulais vous vous interrogez
sur un sujet
qui n'est pas forcément si éloigné que
cela des frontières c'est la sphère
carrefour couche tard vous vous souvenez
que le fabricant le grand distributeur
part dans canadien couche-tard avait
fait des offres de reprises ou en tout
cas de mariage à carrefour et puis c'est
pas aller très loin parce que la semaine
dernière le gouvernement a dit c'est
niet par la voix de bruno le maire
d'où cette question saga nasillard y est
ce que le c'est pas le monde qui est en
train de changer là parce que parce
qu'effectivement il ya les frontières
qui réapparaissent
il ya ce qui s'appelle quand même une
mesure de protectionnisme personne ne
peut croire une seconde dans l'argument
de bruno le maire selon lequel on risque
est plus avoir de nouilles dans les
rayons si on était racheté si carrefour
été racheté par un canadien c'est vous
vous sentez le climat qui change là où
c'est une parenthèse qui se refermera
jeu j'espère que c'est une parenthèse
qui se refermera même si pour l'instant
effectivement les événements ne m'incite
pas être très optimiste
mais vous savez mais ça rejoint
effectivement le débat protectionnisme
contre contre libre échange
moi je suis un défenseur du libre
échange vous savez est un économiste
américain du dix neuvième siècle
s'appelait henri georges qui avait une
très belle formule qui disait que le
protectionnisme c'est s'infliger en
temps de paix ce que nos ennemis nous
inflige en temps de guerre eh bien c'est
exactement ça quand l'administration
américaine promet de lourdes sanctions
pénales à celui qui oserait investit
dans les secteurs stratégiques iranien
eh bien elle ne le fait pas pour
favoriser l'économie iranienne le fait
pour punir l'économie iranienne donc
ceux qui mettent ces punitions et ses
restrictions en oeuvre savent très bien
que la prospérité d'une nation dépend de
sa capacité à accumuler des capitaux
fusse-t-il locaux ou étrangers
et là on a un ministre de l'économie qui
se plaît à dissuader les investissements
étrangers en france et ensuite il ya un
an multipliera les convention citoyenne
pour consoler un peuple déplacé mais
c'est une
une mesure qui complètement contre
productif parce que elle va nuire à
l'attractivité de notre pays et ça qui
bien évidemment conditionne la
prospérité à capacité d'une nation à
accroître son poids économique et rien
d'autre dioum bernard vous avez le
sentiment que c'est une parenthèse qui
me souviens en train de vivre ou bien
que d'aider des signes comme ce comme
ces deux là montrent que peut-être
l'époque du libéralisme est en train de
perdre de son lustre
j'ai théorisé ce qu'on appelle le
mouvement dextrogyre n'est ce pas et
donc sur le fait qu' il y aurait le
retour 10 des plus classique et moins
moderne
le libéralisme c'est parti de la
modernité cela dit je crois que ça va
mettre un certain temps et donc je suis
quand même surtout frappé par
l'incohérence des comment dire des
mesures gouvernementales c'est à dire
que d'un côté on a une traité
international de libre-échange avec le
canada et de l'autre côté on ne permet
pas une entreprise canadienne d'acheter
une entreprise française par ailleurs
j'avoue que je connais pas très bien la
situation de carrefour qui fait de la
grande distribution
enfin il me semble qu'il ya des fleurons
industriels et technologiques français
qui ont été vendus y compris avec
l'accord du gouvernement français et que
c'était peut-être plus problématique
pour l'indépendance nationale que
simplement des magasins donc voilà d'un
côté on a permis la vente de siemens et
le pardon de hilal
c'est par alcatel si alstom la révision
notamment acier mince donc là outre-rhin
j'allais utiliser un terme péjoratif
pardonnez moi donc on a permis cela mais
d'un autre côté effectivement des
magasins de distribution ne peuvent pas
être cédées à des canadiens j'avoue que
je suis extrêmement dubitatifs sur la
cohérence de la politique
gouvernementale
je ne fais pas partie de ceux qui
pensent et ses 1 2 point qui m'oppose à
fergane que l'état a par principe un
rôle alors les socialistes pensent que
par principe il faut avoir un rôle
d'intervention les libéraux pensent
fergane je ne pense pas travailler
travestir votre pensée que a priori ne
doit pas avoir ou du moins il doit avoir
un rôle extrêmement restreint
d'intervention pour ma part je considère
que le rôle de l'état est susceptible de
varier en fonction des circonstances et
que donc par conséquent en période par
exemple de crise
en période de nécessité de défendre
l'indépendance nationale il est normal
que l'état puisse intervenir
donc sur le principe je ne suis pas
choqué que l'état intervienne en
revanche que l'état intervienne pour des
magasins et pas pour de l'industrie
lourde
là en revanche je savais que je ne suis
pas tout à fait ou pour la sidérurgie
j'avoue que je ne suis pas tout à fait
convaincu et à propos de l'industrie
pour être précis ce n'est pas la
division ferroviaire d'alstom et la
division énergie qui a été vendu à 6
masse parce que la division ferroviaire
est non seulement est restée française
mais petit clin d'oeil du destin elle
est en train de finaliser l'acquisition
d'une entreprise canadienne et riz en
l'occurrence bombardier c'est comme quoi
effectivement où l'on constate une
espèce d'hypocrisie française c'est à
dire que lorsqu'on a des entreprises
nationales qui acquièrent des fleurons
étrangers on se dit cocorico mais quand
ce sont des étrangers qui a investi chez
nous et bien là ont tout le monde
dénonce les opérations et les
transactions nationales
c'est une forme de protectionnisme
primaire et qui a des conséquences
extrêmement fâcheuses
un exemple très simple on sait
qu'aujourd'hui que l'une des raisons
pour lesquelles on est exposé à une
pénurie de vaccins c'est parce que
l'europe a fait le choix de privilégier
les intérêts de sanofi au lieu de 2
d'acheter deux commandé auprès des
laboratoires qui avaient de meilleurs
résultats et qui était apparemment
américains donc vous voyez que le
protectionnisme est une philosophie
idiote parce que ce qui devrait
intéresser les acheteurs les états et
des consommateurs s'est simplement la
qualité des produits indépendamment de
leur origine
même si le gardien français a nié avoir
hui retarder les achats pour que je
puisse croire le gouvernement a fait de
la guerre aussi économique et donc par
conséquent il est normal qu'on puisse
utiliser le protectionnisme aux besoins
dans une guerre moderne 1 go sera laissé
à nos internautes on vous a posé de la
question approuvez-vous l'existant
l'exigence d'un test qu'aux vite pour
les européens entre en france bien c'est
oui de façon massive mais a priori c'est
assez logique puisque là pour le coup on
peut laisser les frontières ouvertes
tout en mettant en place des tests
propose de parler d'un sujet qui n'a
vraiment rien à voir encore que c'est
toujours ce satané virus qui est en
train de régler nos belles mécaniques
française et notamment celle du
baccalauréat une réforme du bac et
depuis cette année il y à ce que l'on
appelle les épreuves de spécialités qui
sont donc au choix des élèves de
terminale et ses épreuves elle devait se
dérouler entre le 15 et le 17 mars
prochain
sauf que jean michel blanquer à cause de
la pandémie vient d'annoncer que
finalement il faudrait faire autre chose
écoutez c'était ce matin sur rtl oui
surtout de les remplacer par un autre
mode d'évaluation en l'occurrence le
contrôle continu du premier trimestre du
deuxième trimestre et du troisième
trimestre de façon à ce qu'on travaille
jusqu'au bout et ça change tout quand
même 1 grâce à changer les choses aussi
les preuves sur 3 jours 15 16 et 17 mars
tout à fait donc ça c'est amiri oui même
si un établissement pourra évidemment
organisée
ce jour là si là on a envie d épreuve
qui compteront pour le contrôle continu
donc ce qui se prépare peuvent tout à
fait continuer à le faire avec cette
échéance là mais ce qui comptera pour la
note c'est la moyenne de l'année
est ce que l'enseignant que vous êtes
qui ont berda à une position de principe
pour ou contre le contrôle continu par
rapport aux examens alors ça n'engage
que moi naturellement et pas les
universités dans lesquelles je suis
susceptible d'intervenir je suis plutôt
hostile au contrôle continu
non pas que en soit ce ne soit pas utile
évidemment d'avoir une évaluation
régulière des étudiants mais tout
simplement parce que je crois que
l'examen des vertus le fait de se
préparer à une épreuve le fait d'avoir à
gérer le stress d'une épreuve
c'est une bonne expérience pour pour les
étudiants le fait d'avoir à dans le fond
traiter un sujet dans un temps imparti
eh bien ça me paraît important pour la
vie professionnelle parce que un
entretien d'embauché
c'est comme un examen à l'oral le fait
d'avoir à rendre une copie à une heure
donnée
eh bien ça correspond à ce que l'on fait
tous dans notre vie professionnelle
c'est-à-dire à tenir des délais et à
faire les choses dans un temps dans un
temps imparti donc je suis assez
favorable à l'examen et est plutôt
comment dire hostile au fait de
supprimer les examens et de la remplacer
par un contrôle continu que par ailleurs
il y ait un contrôle continu qui permet
de compenser une botte d'examen parce
qu'on peut bien comprendre que tout joué
toute une année sur une seule épreuve
c'est c'est peut-être injuste mais en
revanche de supprimer les examens pour
ma part je suis je pense que c'est une
mauvaise idée mais je crois que il y a
les raisons vide sanitaire
et puis il ya une autre raison
financière qui me paraît beaucoup plus
vraisemblable c'est que ça va tout
simplement coûter moins d'argent et je
crois qu'il y a à la fois le ministère
et disons un certain nombre de
directeurs d'établissements dans le
supérieur qui sont extrêmement
favorables à ces solutions là parce que
tout simplement ça va leur permettre de
faire des économies
et pourtant ce qui d'ailleurs ne va pas
forcément à l'encontre de ce que vous
pensez mais
jean michel blanquer je peux vous le
dire était vraiment attachés à cette a7
à ces épreuves en tout cas c'est ce qui
nous avait laissé entendre au grand jury
rtl le figaro lci il y a maintenant 15
jours il avait l'air sincère après c'est
ce qu'il l'était ou pas je vous remets
pas en cause la sincérité j'ai eu la
chance de connaître jean michel blanquer
parce qu'il a été mon chargé de td de
libertés publiques mais il ya déjà un
certain temps donc il n'était pas encore
directeur ni ministre donc je suis tout
prêt à croire effectivement le fait
qu'il soit qu'il soit qu'il soit sincère
mais cela dit le fait est que ça peut
permettre de faire des économies que par
ailleurs effectivement
eh bien ils soient contraints par
cohérence avec le reste de la politique
gouvernementale de prendre une telle
mesure
alors je vous livre des commentaires
avant d'entendre le point de vue de
fergane celui de nicole 0,6 sur
lefigaro.fr vu le niveau les résultats
du bac
ça ne va pas changer grand chose demain
on le donnera
serge gainsbourg je craque ce soit un
pseudonyme car malheureusement il n'est
plus parmi nous sur youtube
je ne suis pas certain qu'un contrôle
continu donnera un niveau attendu pour
les élèves en fin de terminale ce que ça
veut dire que c'est moins exigeants dans
l'esprit d'autres internautes sont
sûrement oui et puis le truc après les
maires qu'ovide on va les maires m a et
rer ont va avoir une nouvelle génération
de bacheliers qu'ovide ça ne sent pas
bon
sur twitter nous vous posons la question
approuvez-vous la suppression des
épreuves de spécialités du bac 2021 et
c'est non à 65% ferghana diaries votre
point de vue mais je suis plutôt de
l'avis de guillaume même si j'avoue que
je ne comprends pas l'intérêt de prendre
une décision ou de manière centralisée
uniformiser si c'est juste pour des
contraintes sanitaires est ce qu'on
n'aurait pas intérêt à laisser
conformément au bon vieux principe de
subsidiarité des établissements
s'organiser comme ils le peuvent en
fonction de leurs contraintes
respectives
ce serait bien ce serait pas juste s'il
y en a les élèves en contrôle continu et
que faites-vous de l'égalité
républicaine ne pense pas qu'il faille
confondre égalité d'uniformité
aujourd'hui les établissements dans le
secteur le supérieur n'ont pas les mêmes
programmes n'ont pas les mêmes modes de
certification des compétences et ça
n'empêche pas au marché du travail de
bien fonctionner par ailleurs donc et je
crains qu'aujourd'hui que le bad façon
ne soit qu'une formalité c'est à dire
que bien souvent pour les élèves qui
vont en grande école ou dans les classes
préparatoires
c'est sur dossier et les éclats serait
pas n'attendent pas la fin de gym bac
généralement pour se prononcer en faveur
d'un élève ou d'un autre donc je pense
que c'est une formalité qui occulte le
fait que le contrôle continu qu'on le
veuille ou non on compte beaucoup aux
yeux des responsables d'établissements
dans l'enseignement supérieur ce qui
peut être ce qui est ce qui est fondée
ce qui est ce qui est rationnel parce
qu'on peut aussi se dire que le bac
n'est pas toujours très représentatif de
la performance d'un élève sur sur toute
une année
maintenant si en effet ce sont les
établissements dans le supérieur qui in
fine et choisissent les les aides en
fonction des critères qu'ils estiment
les bons et bien certains mettront des
examens à l'entrée d'autres font passer
des entretiens d'autres s'appuieront sur
le contre on continue donc je ne pense
pas que ça va changer fondamentalement
grand chose puisque rien n'empêche aux
établissements dans le supérieur de
s'organiser d'avoir leur propre
mécanisme de sélection et
d'accréditation et de certification des
compétences des étudiants
mais si on va au bout de votre
raisonnement on supprime le bac purement
et simplement supprimées pas supprimée
pour moi tu encore une fois ça ne change
pas grand-chose parce qu'on peut tout à
fait le maintenir et trouvé ça assez
intéressant maintenant il faut avoir
conscience que ce n'est pas lui qui
détermine tout aujourd'hui le bac encore
une fois aux yeux de beaucoup de
responsables n'est qu'une formalité
il faut bien avoir en tête c'est à dire
qu' il ne suffit pas d'avoir une bonne
note au bac pour pouvoir décrocher
l'établissement de ses rêves
donc c'est un mécanisme de certification
parmi d'autres mais vous savez les
recruteurs dans l'établissement sur
marché de l'emploi sont aussi attentifs
au haut niveau véritable des étudiants
indépendamment de ce que le diplôme
indique d'autant qu'aujourd'hui il ya
une suspicion sur l'affaissement de la
qualité de l'enseignement dans les
établissements français
donc un recruteur vous savez ne va
jamais s'arrêter au baccalauréat il va
toujours creuser un peu plus c'est pour
ça que moi je sous-estiment enfin je ne
pense pas que ça aura que ça aura
énormément d'effet sur l'avenir le
parcours des étudiants
alors justement le problème alors je je
rejoins fergane sur ce point mais
d'autant plus je crois que ça ça ça a
conduit a effectivement s'interroger sur
la suppression des examens parce que il
est bien évident que les dossiers des
étudiants quand il arrive dans le
supérieur vont être regardé en prenant
en considération l'établissement d'où il
vient sur et donc par conséquent le fait
qu'il y ait plus le baccalauréat avec
des épreuves terminales dont on peut
penser qu'il y a une forme je dirais de
2,2 d'uniformité ou d'égalité je dirais
dans la correction
eh bien ça va encore plus renforcée pour
le coup l'impact de l'origine
géographique du du candidat voilà alors
cela dit il ya un point et c'est le seul
point pour lequel je me satisfais je
dirais de la suppression de ces épreuves
c'est que vous le savez il ya ce qu'on
appelle le monopole étatique de la
collation des grades universitaires et
seul l'état et les établissements qui
l'autorisent peut délivrer des grades
universitaires
or le baccalauréat est le premier des
grades universitaires
contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait penser
il ya le bac la licence depuis 99 le
masters et puis le le doctorat avec le
contrôle continu bien cela va permettre
c'est ce qui s'est fait l'année dernière
avec parfois quelques difficultés mais
ça c'est fait déjà si ça se renouvelle
cette année ce sera parfait j'en serais
extrêmement satisfaits le contrôle
continu et donc les notes du contrôle
continu données dans les établissements
hors contrat seront prises en
considération par les jurys du
baccalauréat ce qui signifie que d'une
certaine manière c'est une brèche dans
le monopole de l'état dans la collation
des grades universitaires et c'est
peut-être le seul côté positif de la
suppression de ces épreuves libéral vous
n'êtes pas la concurrence entre les
établissements
elektra de l église simplement on la nie
c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui le bac donne
l'impression que tous les résultats se
valent et de fait quelqu'un qui examine
le dossier d'un élève à henri iv ne va
pas la pressée de la même manière que
qu'un lycée réputé négligent donc il ya
une concurrence qui existe qu'on le
veuille ou non des commentaires
d'internautes si vous le voulez bien
martin sur youtube considère que compte
tenu de la faible mortalité chez les
moins de 20 ans annulé le bac est idiot
flight 94 cela un impact ensuite dans le
supérieur le niveau risque de baisser
pourquoi oui parce qu'il ya des gens qui
du coup pourrait être rattrapé par le
contrôle continu si celui ci est moins
exigeant en termes de note christophe 78
sur lefigaro.fr le bac c'est devenu
l'école des femmes maintenant on va tout
ça nous rajeunit pas mais l'école des
pages vous souvenez que c'était cette
émission de télévision où les enfants
chantent et puis après on leur donnait
une note et en général ils avaient tous
la meilleure possible et puis
vole pas su 34 sur lefigaro.fr ça fait
rire ferghana ziaya qui n'étaient pas
nés c'était hautement jacques martin
finalement c'est une bonne chose
les élèves qui ont travaillé toute
l'année seront récompensés ce ne sera
pas un coup de chance
ça vous paraît malheureusement pour la
réputation de l'établissement les
enseignants ne soit conduit à donner des
bonnes notes
espérons que la hiérarchie entre la
valeur des étudiants sera respectée mais
je crains que malheureusement
aujourd'hui à l'établissement ne ne
prennent pas le risque d'afficher des
résultats de trop de trop grande de trop
nombreux échecs au baccalauréat tout si
votre avis oui au risque d'affaiblir la
confiance finalement dans la capacité de
dellys et a certifié le plus honnêtement
possible
le niveau de ces deux des élèves et ça
ça ça conduira nécessairement les
établissements dans le supérieur
qu'ils soient publics ou privés a
réclamé la possibilité eux-mêmes
d'organiser finalement leur propre
sélection puisque le bac et le lycée et
le contrôle continu jouer ce rôle
et bien si on a plus confiance dans
l'intégrité du certificateur avant
l'entrée dans les études supérieures ce
qui va se passer c'est que les
établissements eux mêmes vont prendre en
charge cette certification moyen de
concours d'entrée d'examen pour
l'entretien pour restaurer finalement
une espèce de contrôle que l'état ne
fait plus en tout cas il faudra être
cohérents c'est à dire que si ça doit se
pérenniser
et bien si la situation que ses organes
décrit doit se pérenniser effectivement
il faudra que les tasseaux cohérent et
considère qu effectivement s'il y a
généré 2 fait des baccalauréats très
différent parce que il y à des
établissements très différents eh bien
il faudra permettre il faudra supprimer
ce mythe par exemple de la licence
unique et et faire que avec une licence
d'établissement avec une licence d'une
université privée
eh bien on puisse par exemple présenté
des concours de l'état ou de se
présenter à des examens pour l'entrée au
barreau ou que sais-je encore
donc par conséquent il faudra être
cohérents plus d'une plus d'unité dans
le baccalauréat plus de monopole de
l'état pour la collation des grades et
la manne des deux se présentent aux
concours
peut-être un bouleversement de plus que
nous apporte cette pandémie
merci beaucoup à tous les deux merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis et très bon
week-end point de vue ça revient lundi à
la même heure au même endroit bonsoir
[Musique]